that this technology community really
digs on Game of Thrones I mean the
dweebs the dorks and nerds you've got
your Venn diagram of overlapping sort of
groups there but this show that is so
anti technological so medieval has a
strong appeal to people in technology
community I think that's one of the
reasons a possible partnership with
Apple may be another reason they held
the premiere for the new season of Game
of Thrones right here in San Francisco
lassen at the Opera House a big party
afterwards at San Francisco City Hall
and and indeed I talked to the fountain
estoy guys it started the show DB Weiss
and damn Benioff and in fact i talked to
marc benioff the CFO CEO of a salesforce
who tried to claim some kind of
ownership on the show which he has no
rights to do but it sort of speaks to
the the level of affection that this
show has in the tech community listen to
what the the guys who started the show
had to say about the role of Technology
in the show it was created by doing some
dork so I would say I mean you know
we're two guys who are playing Dungeons
and Dragons so so we cannot we cannot
make fun of any of the other dorks out
there if you like that we've liked the
show for a different reason than the
doors yeah I think they've got a leech
has drunks or like a whole nother you
don't even want to start whirligigs are
crazy so that happened but it isn't
saying about you there adecco any off
I'm pretty sure he's married to amanda
peet uh he used married amanda paid i
talked to amanda peet last night that's
not very dweeby that's pretty clear no
he's he's doing fine uh no it was
interesting to talk to these people I
talk to us on Peter Dinklage though one
of the great stars of the show for the
pride of Morristown New Jersey about
this sort of anti technological role
that the show has let's know what he had
to say the brains are shutting down a
bit you don't need to remember
moms
number you know it's crazy because it's
right there one of the private
detectives do that's what I always think
back in the day they had to like go down
the rabbit hole now you just go on the
internet and find out everything about
anybody at any time it's crazy my face
over here ya know it's I gotta say that
that there are at least six people I
talked to on the on the red carpet last
night who all claim to be luddites who
hate technology and find themselves
working on this show that's more about
swords and fire than it is about
smartphones and and hacking well in
dragons there are dragons right yeah I
just pull out a little a little Wall
Street trivia for those Game of Thrones
fans who also happen to work at banks
what do you got David Benioff father ran
goldman sachs and the federal reserve
bank of new york yeah his conversations
deva premal have to go back to
delivering pizzas or doing a morning job
where i just tried to decided to try
this show sort of fall flat when you
know about the the financial history of
the thing but it you know I gotta say
like San Francisco turned out last night
and there were huge crowds outside of
the Opera House last night blue suits
were very much in fashion last night as
well you look great I yes I also it
turns out to all of the most actors
knows everything and Jojo are Martin was
also there the author of the of the
books I'm upon which the series is based
and his thoughts about the lack of
technology and innovation was very
interesting because he sort of thinks
it's very long perspective as you might
imagine in a lot of the sort of the
backstory of Game of Thrones is the war
of roses it took place in in England in
the 1600s and and he talks a lot about
sort of how technology hasn't always
gone forward and that's an important
part of the series the question is is
technological progress something that
happens to all societies
and the answer is not necessarily Martin
so the heck of a show look this is me
heck of a season and Matt yes lots of
funny lots of naked you'll like it